jonathan ashworth uh thank you mr deputy
speaker can i just say at the outset
that despite
our fierce political differences that my
dealings with the previous secretary of
state were always courteous
respectful and professional and i wish
him well
in resolving his personal difficulties
now i welcome the right honourable
gentleman to his place and thank him for
advanced sight
of his statement he will find working
with the nhs
and social care staff both inspirational
and rewarding
and i hope he will agree and make
arrangements for them
to receive a fair pay rise and not the
real terms pay cut that is currently
penciled in now today he has let it be
known that july the 19th reopening will
effectively
go ahead he told the news this morning
that there is no going back
that lifting restrictions will be
irreversible
well a word to the wise mr deputy
speaker
i responded to a lot of these statements
these last 15 months i remember
ministers telling us there was nothing
in the data suggests
june 21st wouldn't go ahead i remember
children returning to school for one day
before the january lockdown i remember
it will all be over
by christmas i remember we'll send it
packing in 12 weeks
well we've seen around 84 000 cases in
the last week an increase of around 61
today we've seen the highest case rate
since january if these trends continue
we could hit 35 000 to 45 000 cases a
day
by july 19th that will mean more
long covered he didn't mention both
uncovered that would mean more
disruption
to schooling for some it will mean
hospitalization
and we know that even after two doses
you can catch
and transmit the virus so what is he
going to do
to push infections down vaccination will
do it eventually mr deputy speaker
but not in the next four weeks now i
want to see an end to restrictions our
constituents want to see an end to
restrictions
but i hope his confidence today about
july 19th
does not prove somewhat premature or
even dare i say it
hubristic and can he confirm that by
irreversible
he's ruling out restrictions this winter
and has he abandoned the plan which the
previous secretary of state and
officials were drawing up
for restrictions this winter increased
infections will
impact on the ability of the nhs to
provide wider care
today he has promised to give the nhs
everything they need to get through the
backlog
so will the hospital discharge and
support funding be extended
beyond this september or will trusts
have to make cuts
instead and how does he define getting
through the backlog
when will the nhs again guarantee that
95
of patients will start treatment within
18 weeks
of referral we know thousands are
waiting too long for cancer care
so when will the nhs meet its cancer
target and that 96
of patients wait no longer than a month
from diagnosis
to first treatment when will they give
primary care
the resources to meet the challenge of
the hidden waiting list of over seven
million patient referrals that we would
have expected since march 2010
20. and given the pressures on primary
care is it still his plan to press ahead
with the gp data transfer to be frank mr
deputy speaker
if the department can't keep its cctv
footage secure
how does he expect it to keep our
personal data secure
and will we see a plan to fix social
care or is today's telegraph
correct when it reports that he the
secretary of state
is of the opinion that we are completely
the wrong stage of part of a parliament
to launch a new social care strategy is
that really his view
and given the pressures across the whole
of the healthcare service
will he abandoned the ill-fought through
top-down reorganization of the nhs that
the previous secretary of state was set
to embark on
and finally mr deputy speaker given the
recent questions of propriety
around covid contracts he will
understandably
want to present himself as a new broom
can he confirm that he will not use a
personal email account
to carry out government business can he
explain why the social care minister has
been using a personal email account
to carry out government business and why
was the parliamentary under secretary of
state for innovation the
noble lord bethel using his personal
email account
to discuss the awarding of government
contracts
and why did he have meetings with a firm
that won a contract
but not declare it can he tell us
whether he maintains confidence
in that minister and isn't it time that
that particular health minister
was relieved of their ministerial
responsibilities as well